today I want to talk to you about one of
the most frustrating things and leading
an organization if your leader yourself
you'll know exactly what I'm talking
about you know in in anywhere you look
at in any business you'll always get two
different kinds of people leaders and
leaders and have you ever met somebody
before where you meet with them for the
first time and you walk away saying this
person is so impressive I am so
impressed with this person they are so
amazing they they can do so well they
they can do such great things and then
you ask yourself the real question but
how come to heaven for they've been in a
workforce for 10 years 20 years 30 years
are they just a good talker or they just
good at selling themselves but what is
it well you know leadership is something
that very few people actually see the
work of a leader a leader is not
necessarily the stuff you see on you
know out there when everybody's
recognizing them they're getting a
trophy leadership is really what you do
behind the scenes on a lot of times
behind the scenes leaders who know the
difference between leaders and leaners
okay there's a lot of people majority of
any organization you're in majority
damar leaners and a few the people in
organization are leaders and a lot of
times these leaders inspire are the
leaners to eventually become leaders
every leader was once a leaner leading
on a leader leaning on a leader to learn
so they can duplicate it but i'll say
every time i hire somebody and i bring
somebody and i give him a leadership
position the company anything i've done
over the years when i hire somebody and
i put them in a position where they're
leaning I tell them I said listen you
are the CEO of this department I'm
expecting you to leave this department
I'm expecting you to perform in this
department
I believe you can pull it off but I want
to see you win in this department you're
to see other departments I want you to
leave I don't want you to lean on
everybody all the time waiting for
orders to be given I want you to use
your creative thoughts to create things
in this department that's what I want to
see with you and a lot of times what
happens to people is they'll look at
this and they'll say well I'm a leader
because I'm in the 20% I'll remember
this so this is a tricky thing I'm gonna
tell you the 80/20 rule you know how
this 80% and then 20% are leaders well
once you become the 20% a lot of people
who are in the 20% of that 100% they
stain that 20% but a leader of that 20%
says well wait a minute mid-80s nth or
my the 20% of that 20% then that 20% of
people there is a 20% of that 25
then when they lead to the next level
even in that small group there are
people that lean on others because
everybody's a leader then that 20% says
I minded 20% of that 20% oh yeah 80%
I know it's kind of confusing but our
leaders striving constantly to move up
and to be the 20% to be the 1% to move
up to be the small or leader that's
taking on more responsibility from the
top to mover more leadership positions
from the top so eventually gets to the
top and the person above them says you
know what you can do a better job than I
am you take over my position because
you've been leading for such a long time
I'm proud of you this position is now
yours but it'll only happen to those
that have made a decision and committed
to leading not constantly leaning there
is a big difference when you look at
your organization and your people you
think about when you mark him down it's
very good exercise to write and say this
guy is a leaner
he seems like a lead everybody thinks
he's a leader but he's truly a leaner he
is still leaning when is this guy gonna
start leading my challenge to you is in
every single category of 80/20 you get
to you be the leader of the 20% not the
leaner and the 80%
it's my message of the week to him
please be sure to subscribe to this
channel and comment on the bottom